je crois que rien que là en 2000 révèle
c'est un secret de polichinelle elle
révèle ce qu'on sait déjà c'est à dire
que au fond la france produit des élites
par le système des grandes écoles des
classes préparatoires nos inégalités
scolaires sont excessivement forte bien
plus forte que ne le supposent les
inégalités sociales quant à la
reproduction des inégalités scolaires
on est proche du chili aujourd'hui en
france tellement que tout ça est un prix
clonage social tout ceci on l'a accepté
et pire que ça on l'a défendu moi je
voudrais rappeler mais ça ça serait trop
long les tout petits tentative qu'il y a
eu pour effet former les collèges etc
à chaque fois ça a été un tollé je
dirais je vais être un peu vu vieux
marxistes sur les bords mais comme si
les classes moyennes qui avait compris
qu'elle se reproduisait par ce système
tenez as tu ne bouges jamais alors on
défend la culture les élites la
civilisation tout un tas de trucs
en réalité il ya une jeunesse qui est
complètement du alizés autour de cette
affaire je répète
d'un côté vous êtes sélectionné ça coûte
cher vous êtes bien formés vous avez un
emploi à la sortie qui correspond à
votre diplôme de l'autre côté vous êtes
dans une vague incertitudes vous allez
avoir 4 5 en dessous de ce qu'on appelle
de deux de mélange de chômage deux
stages d'insertion ont fait même
aujourd'hui dans les universités de la
préparation à l'insertion des choses
comme ça et tout ça était relativement
tolérable et évidemment avec la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes tous
ça nous saute à la figure et je trouve
que de ce point de vue là les jeunes
étudiants sont très gentils sont très
pacifique
parce que ils sont en réalité très mal
traité mais ça ne date pas d'hier c'est
une très longue histoire dans notre
système scolaire
[Musique]